how does it feel to have a tiger though
was that like
if listen um you grew up with like he
grew up with you right yeah since a baby
yes and now you saw him
i miss having a tiger i'm sure but you
can't when you have little kids because
they get jealous
like lying they don't want nobody to be
around you but dumb and all that bull
tiger would hang out with all of us in
here you could be chuckling and you he
could choke him
it's not like they just want to be one
person they don't really want to hang
out with anybody else
it's pretty unbelievable yeah i mean
when you have them since they're a baby
that you're you're the parent oh i sleep
with them yeah you're the you're the
you're the father i always sleep with my
cat but they stopped farting at night
[ __ ] on your man you can't imagine
that [ __ ] 700 pound [ __ ] cat oh man
you have to crack the windows oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ] that it's in the door too why
you let these [ __ ] in here mike
and you can't get rid of it because it's
like farting pissing the [ __ ] stains
in the wall and the floor all the
[ __ ]
so i got in their own house and i put
them in the house [ __ ] i bought the
house next door and i made that their
house they got a lot of [ __ ] exotic
pets in the bronx like in the [ __ ]
projects when they were there it's
[ __ ] up right keep the alligators in
the crocodiles
listen the [ __ ] i'm telling you what
you're talking about the [ __ ] had a 500
pound tiger and had a goddamn alligator
in his bathtub and so the alligator in
the line got in the fight and this
[ __ ] in the apartment yeah black
muffler in the tub right in the tub and
there's one bedroom apartment two
bedroom apartments in the bar he had
them since they were a baby i don't know
how you snuck them in there but the the
alligator was in
the goddamn pool the the the the tub and
the cat staying there he started
fighting this guy this [ __ ]
what's in his mind a tiger in the
alligator's fight and he goes hey stop
stop
he's trying to break it up like it's a
regular fight yeah
they put [ __ ] him up
they [ __ ] him up man
and then he's in new york and they're
looking at you got a what a 500 tiger
here alligator how did you do this is it
this guy
look at what it is 25 pound tiger living
in harlem listen
that could be another one
but listen oh that's it no yeah listen
wanna look at that that's look how big
that [ __ ] is holy [ __ ] go back
look at look at this
he's an apartment but that's a one
bedroom apartment building you could
smell them from downstairs
good thing you had the window guards on
there you know what i'm saying because
we can't drive this car these are
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know
these things get this [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
crazy
where the [ __ ] did he get that man i
should get him from black market
yeah listen
blow your mind right in flushing somehow
right now there's more there's more
tigers
and captivity there than a while
that is [ __ ] mind-blowing
so when you see that tiger that is that
is is that a bengal tiger that's a
bangle okay so that is that one that
specific species almost extinct those
are the ones that they're not that many
in the wild the white bangles the white
bangles fig oh okay
and you had that one yeah you had that
one but some of them are pure white you
guys got um like gray stripes or
something you gotta yeah i don't know
what you did this white but you gotta
you gotta um shake shake and see the
strength oh [ __ ]
the regular ones are endangered
of course they're beautiful those are
unbelievable it's like that that animal
he's ready to shoot a tranquilizer gun
he's ready to blast him yeah see that's
[ __ ] up before he laughed that's
[ __ ] up he's been blasting with the
shoddy right there that happened range
that cat is so scared they've never been
in never seen a person before other than
his trainer so they brought this club
home at eight weeks but look at the guy
that had the crocodile in the tiger
fighting in the in the tub
hopefully they didn't kill it
well they [ __ ] hitler
he's just chilling in the living room
like it's nothing that's not cool man
[Music]
also when you have those crate like just
to have those [ __ ] crazy things that
are just
listen um from the wild wild like that
like africa and amazon in the apartment
though
this room right here you have to chill
out
[Music]